Welcome back everyone this will be my full video
for the boys season 3 episode 4 there were
a whole bunch of easter eggs wtf moments to break
down so if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're doing
a giveaway for that amazon prime service all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and just
leave your favorite moment from the episode on
the video the boys is one of those tv shows that
just keeps getting crazier no matter how many
terrible things happen things always wind
up getting crazier in future episodes
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet we'll just start at the beginning
and work our way through scene by scene talking
about easter eggs and wtf moments starting with
the episode title the glorious 5-year plan the
episode title is mostly a reference to the comic
book arc of the same name which itself is based on
the in-universe soviet-era superhero team glorious
five-year plan which love sausage was a member of
who they did during season two is also meant to be
a reference to the russians trying to use soldier
boy's blood to give superpowers to other russian
military members but as you can see they only
have one hamster who's still alive with compound v
powers the whole thing with compound v is that not
everybody can take it and survive it usually winds
up killing most the people that try it but i did
love all the jokes about jamie the hamster that
winds up killing all those russians don't worry
i'll talk about that when we get to that part of
the episode because they kind of use soldier boy
in a very captain america way like he's a parody
of captain america but this episode uses him in
more of a winter soldier kind of way where he's
stolen by the russians like winter soldier
was secretly stolen by the russians in hydra
and turned into an assassin that's kind of
what's going on with soldier boy's arc during
the series it seems like they're going to try and
use him as a weapon against homelander eventually
because of his ability now that we've learned
to nullify other superheroes healing factors
but the glorious 5-year plan is also a reference
to stan edgar's grand plan that he explained in
episode 1 to get control of the white house and
basically transition the company to more of a
pharmaceutical company like getting rid of all
the superheroes because they're not as profitable
as just being a regular pharmaceutical company
the actual opening scene is of mother's milk
watching an old tv recording of soldier boy from
the 80s of this weird vot tv show that they were
promoting at the time with this funny hip-hop song
performance that he was doing it's meant to be a
parody of william shatner's rock man performance
in other performances like that where you have
celebrities doing a really bad job performing a
song or something like that like the whole joke is
how terrible he actually is at singing this is his
family before soldier boy killed them back in the
80s when he was a young child like this is him as
a kid they have this funny scene with homelander
going on the vot controlled vnn network with this
news host it's like an in-universe version of
cnn but because voc controls the network they
basically tell him what he's supposed to say
trying to control what the public thinks and sees
but the other joke here is that when he's yelling
about conspiracy theories shadow conspiracies
inside vaught he's actually telling the truth
because stan edgar was really controlling
everything the superheroes were doing this
whole time the whole idea with the boys is that
everybody is terrible stan edgar trying to control
all sides of the game tries to get victoria newman
to use her agency to secretly reprimand homelander
in public just to discipline him because you can't
physically discipline homelander like nobody could
arrest him theoretically but i think the big
twist in that is the way that they're using the
soldier boy character which i'll talk about in a
second because now they actually potentially have
a deterrent against homelander this is also meant
to be a reminder dovetailing with the conversation
that he has with homelander later talking about
controlling all sides of the game playing both
sides of the board to potentially win because
stan edgar's real plan is to eventually control
the government and just make the company more
profitable at the end of the day stan edgar wants
to do the same thing that homelander is doing
just using different methods he wants to control
the world just in a different way controlling
what people think he thinks that's real power
as he told his starlight in episode one butcher
uses frenchie's old russian boss to get the boys
into russia so they can find what they think is a
weapon to fight homelander but the big joke being
that it's actually soldier boy and the other joke
bringing things back around is that it is actually
a weapon that they can use to kill homelander just
not the kind of weapon that they thought it was
they have this big joke about butcher using the
cia's clean american money to pay off frenchie's
debt from his friend that stole the drugs from
her and how the government will just print more
of it if they want to to show you that even
though they're trying to stop homelander from
taking over the world and stan edgar from also
trying to take over the world in a different way
what the legitimate government is doing
isn't that much better it's also a reference
back to mallory's story about what the reagan
administration had been doing profiting off the
drug trade through the cia and using that to fund
their war against the russians by proxy with the
iran contra incident like mother's milk revealing
also during the 80s that the cia used these drugs
inside underprivileged neighborhoods in ghettos
and kept them out of white neighborhoods and it
was this really really sinister thing that
the government sanctioned remember it all
comes back to the idea that every different
person on the boys is terrible on some level
they have this huge joke about a train trying
to help the community by getting rid of blue
hawk but then they have the big joke about the
turbo rush soft drink ad that he shoots that's
meant to be a parody of that kendall jenner pepsi
ad from a couple years ago that itself was just
absolutely terrible and totally in bad taste the
whole idea here is that vot doesn't care anything
about helping the underprivileged they just care
about making more money at the end of the day
which all dovetails with stan edgar's grand plan
to turn them into more of a pharmaceutical company
selling the compound v to the military because
it's more profitable even though it kind of looks
like butcher is gonna sell frenchie out to the
russians to get what he wants i don't think it's
gonna take it that far this early in the show but
in the comics butcher really is that terrible of a
person he is willing to do anything to accomplish
his goals that's why he's meant to be just as bad
as homelander just in a completely different
direction when they have the whole huey and
homelander scene with him learning the truth about
what he's done how he's going to make starlight
his girlfriend when he jokes about having a key to
her place and watching her while she sleeps that's
only partly a lie he doesn't actually need keys
to get into locked doors because he's so powerful
but we've learned in previous seasons that he's
not above using his super sight and super hearing
to spy on everyone all over the place so
he really is probably watching you sleep
when he says maid can bend a steel pipe with
her vajay and then later starlight goes to talk
to maeve and she basically says kind of the same
thing oh have you heard all these terrible things
about me about how i get drunk all the time about
how i'm a huge well i like people to believe what
i want them to believe so is them kind of doing
the comic book plot because all that stuff is
actually true in the comics but on the tv show
they're just using that as sort of a front so
that she can get it homelander may's also not
lying when she's talking about how she plans on
helping the boys against homelander when she says
she'd only be able to buy them a couple seconds to
potentially kill homelander is because homelander
is so much stronger than her and everyone else
they have a couple references to that during the
episode where homelander challenges other people
to use their powers on him like he even
challenges victoria newman why don't you
try to pop my head and see if it works because
nothing is able to kill him no matter what they
try like victoria newman probably could not use
her ability against him it probably wouldn't work
that's why previously i said that i think that
ryan will wind up being the big deterrent to
homelander long term but now they have the
temporary soldier boy character who can use his
powers to nullify his healing factor theoretically
so that might be able to help them but for example
they couldn't just give that temporary compound v
to a bunch of military members and squads and use
that against them because they physically would
not be able to last against homeland or it become
a fight of attrition and eventually all their
compound v would wear off they just would not
be powerful enough to kill him that's why they're
trying to set up this whole thing with soldier boy
being able to put a debuff on him essentially just
turning off his healing factor temporarily butcher
makes an entourage joke when they board that
russian's private plane all over russia there's
graffiti of homelanders the seven depicting them
as evil hurting everyone because that's secretly
the truth are all terrible and the russian tv
networks also making fun of what's going on
in present day with the seven well secretly the
russian military all these years has been using
the blood from soldier boy to try and create their
own superheroes i'll explain that in a second too
because there's a reason why you don't see tons
of russian superheroes running around all over
the place the whole thing with butcher using
chemical as a weapon is more about him just
becoming more and more of a terrible person just
like homelander the whole side plot with kimiko
killing the russian is meant to show you how
strong she is how strong her compound v abilities
are she can literally shrug off headshot wounds
from bullets doing this to show you why soldier
boy is such a huge deal because at the end of the
episode when she soaks his damage from his special
ability her healing factor is basically nullified
temporarily like oh this is probably going to come
in handy against homelander frenchie and her
also talk about running off to france together
leaving the boys they might wind up paying that
off by the end of the series if they both survive
to the end of the series they have this big
joke about this russian oligarch having sex
toys based on all the seven characters which she
winds up killing them all with in really wtf ways
the other funny thing here too is that technically
she doesn't need weapons to kill people because
she's so strong with compound v-powers she herself
is the weapon then back in the tower of the seven
starlight telling supersonic about half of their
plan to kill homelander is literally what winds up
getting him killed later i think the whole idea
with a train informing on what their plan was
is just him becoming just as dark as the other
characters in paying back to huey's comment to
starlight saying we have to be just as bad as the
other guys in order to beat them like everyone all
over the show all these different characters are
getting worse and worse as people to try and beat
the other guy the whole thing with him joking
about their former relationship i think all this
is meant to be true like he doesn't secretly pine
for her or anything like that he just meant to
be a generally good guy so that when they reveal
what homelander did to him it feels that much more
tragic i did laugh pretty hard when you see the
deep just dig into those tacos just stuffing his
mouth right after we saw him stuffing his mouth
with his friend timothy the octopus r.i.p timothy
this big joke about the deep doing anything to
please homelander he's willing to literally eat
his friends to please homelander the whole thing
with his wife also telling him what to say during
that to back homelanders play when a train speaks
up about blue hawk is also meant to show you how
weak will the deep is like literally everybody on
the show so far has been controlling his actions
he just seems like he'll do whatever anyone tells
him to do they also remind you that both the deep
and a train tried to do something with the boys
to stop homeland or previously so they both have
a lot of dirt on each other and they're kind of
at a stalemate it's just the deep seems like he's
in a stronger position just because currently
homelander likes the deep more than a train
then they actually reference the time when butcher
met mother's milk back in the military all that
stuff about him being in the brig getting into
trouble with the military is similar to the
comic backstory but the difference is that in the
comics mother's milk had compound v powers himself
he still wound up in the military like the tv
show version but in the comics when he drank his
mother's milk it made him super strong that's
why his name is mother's milk then the whole
twist with victoria newman turning on steneger is
because she's afraid homelander is going to kill
her and her daughter and it's all meant to be true
like she is actually afraid of homelander killing
them they revealed that she previously went to
homelander and preemptively offered him a deal
in exchange for the compound v to protect her
daughter to give her daughter compound b powers
homelander later jokes about this when he's
telling the others about what's going on with
the news broadcast he's making a move against stan
edgar for control of everything that's going on
thinking that he's in control now but i'll talk
about this in a second too they just want to
make you feel like he's won the day like this is a
temporary victory for him in this episode but it's
probably going to be very short-lived but that's
why at the end of the episode you see her give the
regular compound v to her daughter and it is blue
so it's meant to be regular permanent compound v
so that even though victoria newman is a dirt
bag they want to show you how much she does
care about her daughter when homelander comes to
give victoria newman the compound v in all those
files of stan edgar's he's not lying to her about
senegar having contingency plans against her too
because as he says later in the episode when
he's talking to homelander he tries to play every
single angle but i think the idea is that he did
genuinely care about her like he did think of her
as a daughter is just that also he's playing this
four-dimensional chess game he's a complicated guy
he's like the gus fring of the boys universe they
have another joke about ashley venting her rage
being super freaky with that vnn host just having
this super crazy kink dealing with all the crazy
stuff that happens in this really messed up way to
make a family guy reference she's kind of like the
meg of the show they have this big running joke
about how everybody mistreats ashley and she just
winds up having to take it all they have the big
homelander versus stan edgar scene and it's meant
to pay off the reference about stan edgar's plan
to phase out superheroes like you may have thought
that you've won but you've won nothing loved his
ultimate takedown of homelander you're not a god
you're just simply a bad product all just paying
off the idea that he really just cares about
making the company more efficient more profitable
and they can make way more money just selling the
temporary compound v to the government for the
military when he says no one is here to cover
up all your mess-ups saying that homelander is
kind of a stupid person at the heart of it and
eventually he'll wind up revealing his true hand
to the world and go full evil superman on everyone
my big theory now because stan edgar's still
alive like he walks away very much alive at the
end of this episode is that just like during
season two he and butcher will make a deal
to work with each other like the enemy of my
enemy is my friend kind of thing because just
like season 2 they both hated homelander and
they wanted a deterrent against him and now
that butcher has soldier boy and they have the
ability to nullify homelanders healing factor
stan edgar will help them try to use soldier
boy's power against homelander but then when
they actually find soldier boy mother's milk makes
a bunch of 80s movie references during red dawn
the russians invade a u.s town the locals have
to fight them off during rocky iv rocky winds up
defeating the russians and they find that russians
have been pulling a winter soldier captain america
reference by keeping soldier boy in cryo all these
years trying to use his blood in an experiment to
give powers to their soldiers that's literally
the plot of captain america civil war with
hydra trying to create some of their own super
soldiers with diluted serum the whole joke about
the hamster named jaime is that he was a test
subject there's a bunch of cages nearby him so
they clearly experimented a bunch of animals and
jaime's just the only one that survived the reason
his hair's so long is because the powers that he
got from soldier boy's blood just helped him live
way longer than normal hamsters allowing his hair
to keep growing and because he's too dangerous for
the russians to try and cut his hair so they just
kept him in this reinforced cage the whole time
and i love the way that they pay off the joke too
by having jaime free himself in like this little
tiny flying hamster that's super strong killing
the russians with his powers hopefully this is not
the last time that we see jaime the super powered
hamster but the reason why you don't see tons of
russian superheroes running around all over the
place is one because stan edgar kind of keeps
it on the qt and because compound v is so volatile
very few people are able to survive the treatments
butcher reveals his powers to the rest of the boys
kind of pissing them off like why have you done
this to yourself you're just as bad as homelander
and that's all true but they also have the joke
with huey's powers revealing that he also stole
the last dose for himself his abilities look like
teleporting and super strength i'm assuming those
are the only abilities that he got the reason why
he's naked is because his teleporting ability only
allows him to teleport himself not his clothes
that's why he teleports out of the cast the
whole thing with huey getting compound v powers
they want to make it clear that butcher did not
give him that last remaining file he was stolen
so remember they only had three and now they
don't have any more they could potentially steal
more but i think the idea is that they're out of
compound b and now they have to rely on soldier
boy to try and fight homelander and they treat
it like it's this bad thing like potentially he's
becoming corrupted he treats it like he's just
taking drugs he looks like he's kind of high here
but when they reveal what happened to soldier boy
if it wasn't clear what really happened to him in
the flashbacks what actually happened is the
russians were able to disable him temporarily
capture him in cryostasis and i think stan edgar
might have secretly known about this long term
like he's always wanted to play both sides
of the aisle so he allowed the russians to
take soldier boy so that he could use that as
a reason to get superheroes in the military
like oh you need this compound fee because look at
all the superheroes that the russians have they're
going to take over the world if you don't buy
all my compound v i already explained his backup
power too it seems like he's able to dampen
superhero healing factors because kimiko will
probably eventually heal but it'll probably just
take her way longer to actually heal the damage
with them potentially using that to fight home
later like turning off his healing factor so that
even though he might be super strong they can
still actually injure him and even though they
tease the boys group is breaking up like mother's
milk says oh there's no more group anymore that's
probably also just temporary they just want it
to feel like homelander won the day when really
it's just a temporary setback for everyone when
he says he's got something that's going to blow
starlight's mind it's a reference to the deal
he just made with victoria newman helping gain
control of the company and him killing super
sonic because like i said they want it to seem
like he's won the day but everyone let me know in
the comments if soldier boy is supposed to be like
the douchey version of captain america how do you
think they're going to use him to fight homelander
and if there are any big easter eggs in the
episode that you spotted that i didn't talk about
in the video just write them below in the comments
my full video for the boys season 3 episode 5 will
post next week just like normal i've also got a
couple new marvel and dc trailers that i'm working
on that'll post next be sure to enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss those and everyone
click here for my marvel thunderbolts movie
video and click here for all the voice season
3 episodes thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!